live at four
[Music]
this is eight news now every three
minutes someone is diagnosed with a
blood cancer one minute you're young and
healthy the next you can barely walk up
a flight of stairs that's exactly what
happened to a young las vegas woman
denise is joining us in studio now with
her story in today's healthwatch denise
well christian her road to recovery
means finding her match in the worldwide
bone marrow registry and for thousands
of critically ill blood cancer patients
there is a cure and it could be you by
sharing her struggle she hopes it might
inspire you to be the match
kind of like an episode where i went up
the stairs
and my heart was just racing like i had
just sprinted a marathon beyond feeling
debilitated 30 year old madison friedel
also had suspicious bruising after
months of unexplained symptoms family
urged her to get checked out if you
don't go to the er
i'm going to call an ambulance to come
pick you up that put the unlv grad on a
path of countless tests her diagnosis
devastating i've had in total about
three bone marrow biopsies
and they have diagnosed me with aplastic
anemia which is complete bone marrow
failure that failure causes critically
low blood counts her best chance for a
full recovery a bone marrow transplant
it was a long shot but her half-sister
miranda may be her miracle the sisters
share the same mother but different dads
so the results are back and
you're my match
and i was just like
oh my gosh like happy tears from
everybody
doctors were able to check eight out of
ten boxes so a life-saving transplant is
possible i know i know it's crazy i was
just so excited
to finally have this step and i can save
my sister's life and everybody is just
like
las vegas isn't able to provide the
specialist or the resources needed so
she and her fiance are traveling to
seattle for treatment her family's
support team is there too 100 days of
constant monitoring and if if all goes
well i'll be able to come back to vegas
around january insurance covers most of
the procedure but a gofundme hopes to
raise enough to cover a long list of
other expenses to help a young woman in
the fight for her life very humbling
experience to see people reaching out
and
i'm very grateful for it
now the sisters want to encourage
everybody to join the bone marrow
registry now listen to this out of more
than 20 million people worldwide madison
found one person that was a 10 out of 10
a perfect match but that person withdrew
she got lucky her sister was pretty
close so the more people who register
the more chances that people like
madison might find their lifesaver i'll
keep you posted on her progress back to
you